Hello, everyone. It's
Dr. Carl Abraham with
this lecture on the
role of immunizations
for the module public
and global health.
So by the end of
this lecture, you
should be able to
explain how vaccines
protect individuals
and populations,
distinguish major
vaccine types and
platforms, describe
immune mechanisms
of vaccine-induced
protection,
compare efficacy
and effectiveness,
provide examples
of vaccines that
prevent infectious
and non-infectious
diseases, identify
contraindications
and common
adverse events,
and communicate
with vaccine
-hesitant patients
effectively.
I've put a QR code
in for the scholar rx
brick that corresponds
to this lecture
there are going to be
several slides that
have a lot of
information on them you
are not responsible
for knowing all of
this this first slide
is a list of some
of the current u.s
vaccines that are
licensed in the united
states i'm going to
use the abbreviations
for these vaccines
throughout this
lecture, so this slide
is only for reference
if you need it.
So why are vaccines
important? I think for
many of you, this is
going to be common
sense, but there is
a lot of conflict and
misinformation now about
vaccines, so it's very
important that we
remain on the same page.
Without a doubt,
vaccines are
among the most effective
interventions in
medical history.
They prevent
morbidity, mortality
and disability resulting
in the promotion
of wellness
throughout the lifespan.
These are not
just disease
prevention medications.
These are preventions
that promote wellness.
Vaccines dramatically
reduce health care
burden and costs,
and they protect
vulnerable populations
who are unable to produce
an immune response
through herd effects.
For example, those
who are immune
suppressed or have a
contraindication to
vaccines or have
limitations to availability
of vaccines, such as
refugees, areas of
overcrowding, and
low-income countries.
And vaccines
are incredibly
important to
prevent or attenuate
outbreaks, epidemics,
and pandemics.
Viral infection.
Bacterial infections are
somewhat similar. You
are susceptible to
an infection if you
do not have immunity
from prior infection
or prior vaccination.
Once you are exposed to
a virus for the first
time, it stimulates
B cells to produce
IgM. However, that
production may take several
weeks. It is during
that time that one
develops the illness as
IgM does not have the
efficacy or capacity
to attenuate disease
the way that other
antibodies do, such as
IgG. However, As you
know, B cells are not
able to produce IgG
until the class switch.
That occurs after the
production of IgM,
but eventually IgG
does reduce symptoms
and control the
infection. And then
memory cells are able
to rapidly stimulate
B lymphocytes to
produce IgG on
subsequent exposures
to prevent disease.
the result of
vaccination is to take
place of that
primary exposure and
infection in other
words it primes the
immune system for a
secondary response
with IgG without the
burden of disease.
One of the myths
about vaccines is
that natural infection
produces immunity
that's better
or stronger than
vaccines. And actually,
that's not true.
As we've gotten
better and better
vaccines, we have
some vaccines that
produce immunity
and reduce the risk
of severe disease
or poor outcomes
even better than
natural infection.
Another important
concept about
vaccination is
herd immunity.
We talk a lot about
this with measles and
influenza. We talked
a lot about it during
the COVID pandemic.
And what it
essentially means is
that if you are infected,
you are much less
likely to infect other
people if everyone
around you is immune.
So at the top of
this graphic, you see
that almost everybody
is not immune and
there are some people
who are sick and
that results in
everyone getting sick.
However, as more and
more people are immune,
the less likely it
is that somebody who
is ill transmits that
illness to somebody
else. And that's what
herd immunity is.
Vaccines play a
very important
role, both
internationally and
nationally, as
well as regionally.
But you could
imagine that in some
areas of the world, in
low-income countries,
the life expectancy
of children
approaches that of
the turn of the 20th
century for the
entire world at that
time, which was
about 50% mortality.
That's horrifying.
So much of that was
improved by sanitation
and clean water.
But after that,
vaccines are
incredibly important to
reduce infant and
child mortality.
It is said that
probably sanitation is
responsible for about
two thirds of the
improvement in child
and infant mortality,
while vaccines are
about one third. So in
much of the world,
there is a lot of work
to be done to improve
childhood mortality.
Vaccines also
decrease the potential
for pandemics and
epidemics worldwide.
They decrease
antimicrobial use,
especially inappropriate
antimicrobial
use, and therefore
decrease the tendency
for bacteria to
become resistant.
and they also
decrease dramatically
healthcare cost and
burden. I don't know how
many of you know
what COVID did to the
healthcare system in
the United States and
they're around the
world, but I'll give you
a quick example. If
all of your ambulances
are transporting
patients with COVID
to hospitals that are
able to care for them
from smaller
hospitals, there are no
ambulances to pick you
up if you're having
a myocardial infarction
at home. That was
actually happening
in the United States.
And very importantly,
there has been a
disease completely
eradicated smallpox from the
world and we're almost
there with polio.
However, if we
decrease the number
of people who are
being vaccinated
in the United
States for polio,
we will see a resurgence
of that disease.
Another slide with
lots of information
on it. This is not
for you to memorize,
but it is to
point out that
when we talk
about vaccinating
somebody for,
say, influenza,
we're not just
stopping acute
viral influenza.
We're also reducing
the risk of
viral pneumonia,
secondary bacterial
pneumonia,
acute encephalitis,
encephalopathies,
asthma exacerbations,
COPD exacerbations.
And the most recent
literature suggests
that decreasing the
prevalence of influenza
during influenza
season decreases
patients presenting to
the hospital with
myocardial infarction,
******, gastrointestinal
hemorrhage, and
other non-infectious
illnesses. This is
also being shown by
the new RSV vaccine.
It is important to
remember, all of these
viral and bacterial
illnesses have other
sequelae that can
be deadly during the
time of infection
and many of them have
post-infectious
sequelae that can be
devastating to their
health or even fatal.
And I've highlighted
here some of
the more important
complications
of vaccine
-preventable illnesses.
Some you can look up
on your own time, but
we'll go through a
couple of them here.
Subsclerosing
panencephalitis is a post
-infectious complication
of measles. You
probably heard about
it in prior lectures.
It occurs in about one
in 10,000 cases and
is a fatal neurodegenerative
disorder. It
is absolutely tragic.
And as we experience
tens of thousands
of cases of measles,
we will see cases.
Another very common
post-infectious
xeculi is postherpetic
neuralgia after her
bisoster infection.
These patients may
have months, years, or
even lifelong severe
pain at the site of
healed shingles that
severely affects
their quality of life.
They are miserable.
The risk of all of
these complications
are dramatically
reduced by vaccination.
different vaccines use
different mechanisms
of action in order to
provide immunity for
different diseases
and i've listed on the
left the different vaccine
platforms that we'll
talk about in depth
in the subsequent
slides but what happens
if you don't have an
available vaccine or an
infectious illness or
what happens if you
need something right
away that can treat an
infection that is quite
severe and you can't
wait for a vaccine
to cause immunity and
in those instances we
can give passive
immunity this is either
preparations of immune
globulins, for example,
IVIG, which is a mix
of different immune
globulins derived
from human plasma or
rabies immune globulin
or hepatitis B immune
globulin, which is
concentrated antibodies
against those infections.
Or we can give
monoclonal antibodies
that are produced
by manufacturers in
high volume that act
against specific diseases
such as palivizumab
for RSV infection
or casirivimab and
devimab for SARS-CoV
-2. And you've probably
heard of other
monoclonal antibodies
that we give for
autoimmune disease or
malignancies such as
adalimumab or rituximab.
So let's talk about
these vaccine platforms.
We'll first talk about
live attenuated virus
vaccines. Examples
are the measles, mump,
rubella, varicella,
rotavirus, live attenuated
influenza vaccine,
yellow fever, oral
polio vaccine, and the
oral typhoid vaccine.
these vaccines cause
replication of intact
but weakened pathogens
in the host so the
people who are being
vaccinated it's pretty
cool they can actually
be cold adapted that
means that they replicate
at colder temperatures
better than they do
at warmer temperatures
this is the case for
the live attenuated
influenza vaccine,
which replicates really
well in your nose and
upper airways, but
doesn't replicate well
at all in the lungs.
These result in strong,
long-lasting humoral
and cellular immunity,
another B cell,
in other words, B cell
and T cell. However,
since their replication
in the host,
since they replicate
in the host, they are
contraindicated in
immune suppressed
individuals, including
those who are
pregnant. So anybody
with a low CD4 count,
think untreated
advanced HIV and AIDS,
people who have
received transplants,
transplanted organs
or bone marrow
transplants, who are
on immunosuppressive
medications, or those
who are receiving
cytotoxic chemotherapy
for cancer.
inactivated vaccines
for example the
inactivated polio vaccine
which we use in the
united states we don't
use the oral polio
vaccine in the
united states the
hepatitis a vaccine rabies
inactivated influenza
and full killed
pertussis these are
pathogens that are
inactivated by heat
radiation or chemicals.
There's no intact
pathogen here, so
therefore there is no
replication in the host.
The virus literally
doesn't exist, so
it cannot replicate.
These produce very
strong humoral
antibody responses
and somewhat strong
but not as strong T
-cell immunity. They
do produce very long
-lasting immunity
if they are given
more than once or
given with adjuvants,
usually both.
And they can be
given in pregnancy
and to the immune
compromised.
Unit vaccines, for
example, the hepatitis
B vaccine or this
Shingrix vaccine, the
Shingrix is a varicella
vaccine for shingles,
and the Nolavax COVID
vaccines are those
that only contain specific
antigens needed to
produce the immune
response. These antigens
are either proteins
or glycoproteins.
They're manufactured
in a factory from the
genetic code for these
antigens in cultures
of cells at scale.
The antigens are then
purified from the cells.
Administration usually
requires adjuvants or
boosters. An adjuvant
is a protein or
carbohydrate that is
linked to antigens in
order to boost the immune
response. Boosters,
which I've mentioned
before, are additional
doses of vaccine
given at later times.
Since only the antigens
are present in the
vaccine, these vaccines
tend to have a very
good safety profile.
Oxoid vaccines are
similar, but it's an
inactivated bacterial
toxin in the vaccine,
and these prevent
toxin-mediated diseases
such as diphtheria or
tetanus. For example,
antitoxin antibodies
in the tetanus
vaccine neutralize
tetanospasmin and
prevent this toxin
from binding to
receptors in the CNS
and causing disease.
Primarily,
toxoid vaccines
produce an antibody
response, but not
a T-cell response.
Importantly, these
vaccines do not affect
bacterial growth,
but instead prevent
the effect of the
toxin on host tissue.
These vaccines also
require boosters.
Polysaccharide
vaccines, for example,
the pneumococcal
vaccine PPSV23,
contain capsular
polysaccharides. In other
words, they're
polysaccharides from
the coat that
surrounds the capsule.
Because you can
put many different
polysaccharides into
the vaccine, These
vaccines provide
immunity to many
different serotypes
of pneumococcus.
Unfortunately, they
provide poor memory
in infants and poor
T-cell activation,
and immunity is
less long-lived
with polysaccharide
vaccines.
Conjugate vaccines,
for example, the
haemophilus influenza
type B vaccine, the
pneumococcal vaccines,
PCV13, 15, and 20,
and the meningococcal
vaccine, MenACWY,
have polysaccharides
attached
to a protein carrier.
This converts the
response to a T
-cell-dependent
vaccine that is very
durable and long
-lasting. And in addition,
these are effective
in infants.
And finally, the last
two we'll talk about
are mRNA and viral
vector vaccines.
Examples of the mRNA
vaccines are Moderna and
Pfizer's COVID-19
vaccine, but another
vaccine that isn't
in use is the Moderna
CMV vaccine that was
being studied for
about 15 years prior
to the COVID pandemic
for persons with organ
transplant. plant.
These are mRNA
segments within a lipid
nanoparticle
carrier. The lipid
nanoparticle actually
prevents the mRNA from
being degraded by
enzymes in the host.
That allows the
mRNA segments to be
delivered to local
lymph nodes where
B cell and T cell
stimulation occurs.
the antigen is made
very rapidly in the host
cell cytoplasm and
these result in very
strong and durable
antibody and t-cell
responses in other words
these are very long
-lasting in vaccines or
long-lasting immunity
from these vaccines
they also have very low
manufacturing cost
compared to other vaccines.
They can cause rare
side effects, but
the side effects that
they cause other than
pain at the vaccination
site, which is
pretty common, are quite
rare. And you'll see
that that is a pattern
for infections and
vaccines. For example,
the carditis that
occurs after the mRNA
vaccine occurs much less
frequently and to a
lesser severity after
the vaccine compared
to natural infection.
Viral vector vaccines
are harmless viruses.
In other words, most
of the genes to code
for the virulence
factors of the virus have
been removed and instead
these vectors are
just shells with some
genetic information and
antigens that are
harmless or the genes
that code for the antigens
that are harmless.
And when injected
into the host, they
cause very strong
cellular immunity.
Unfortunately, if
you've already been
infected with the
disease, These viruses are
less effective because
your own immune
system stops these
vaccines from working.
And there is the
rare thrombosis with
thrombocytopenia
syndrome that was seen in
the J&J COVID vaccine.
The Ebola virus is
another example of a
viral vector vaccine.
Contraindications
to vaccines are
listed on this slide.
The first is any
severe allergic
reaction, such as
anaphylaxis to the
vaccine antigens or
any other components
of the vaccine.
Another is known
severe immunodeficiency
for patients
and their close
contacts for live
attenuated vaccines.
A history of
interception is a
contraindication to the
rotavirus vaccine, which
does carry a very
slight increased risk
after administration,
and pregnancy
is a contraindication
to live vaccines.
Side effects of
vaccines are incredibly
common, but
usually they're
short-lived and minor,
such as soreness
or redness at the
injection site.
Many vaccines cause
a pretty vigorous
immune response.
So it's not
surprising to have
some fever, chills,
body aches, and fatigue.
That happens
especially with
the influenza
and MMR vaccines.
And because they're
not feeling well,
many children
just aren't in the
best mode after
getting a vaccine.
But serious side effects
are rare. Guillain
-Barre occurs after
influenza about one to
two cases per minute.
I'm sorry, per million.
Anaphylaxis to
the influenza
vaccine is very rare.
Febrile seizures
occur in one to in 3
,000 children who
get the MMR vaccine.
There is a syndrome
of swelling of the
entire limb after
getting a DTaP and there
are definitely adolescents
who faint after
getting the HPV
vaccine. That's a little
bit more common, but
it's not dangerous.
There have been cases
of severe allergic
reactions to the
hepatitis B vaccine due
to Zist that is in
the vaccine from
production. But again,
this is quite rare.
D'Ambri is a rare
risk in seniors
after the
shingles vaccine.
And again,
allergy to vaccine
components can happen
to any vaccine.
what information can
we give our patients
about how well
vaccines work first
we need to know the
difference between
efficacy and
effectiveness efficacy
is the reduction
of disease that are
going in controlled
trials and published
in journals that is
what we You read.
Effectiveness is
the real world
performance, which
is always not as good
as the efficacy
shown in trials.
When you're at home,
you may not adhere
to a dosing schedule
versus when you're
on a trial, because
there are people
who work in trials
who will call you
and make sure you
come in for your dose.
There are errors in
handling of storage
in physicians' offices
and pharmacies.
The host annealing
status influences
whether a vaccine
will work.
The pathogen can
evolve, for example,
the different strains
of SARS-CoV-2.
And there are
socioeconomic barriers
to actually
going and getting
vaccines for a lot
of people. And the
outcomes that are
measured for efficacy
and effectiveness
are different.
One measures infection
prevention, or
another trial may measure
reduction in severe
disease. So those
are two different
numbers, while others
may measure prevention
of complication
or reduction of
transmission. So you've
got to be cognizant
of what the trial is
actually measuring.
For example, the
influenza vaccine.
This works by
producing neutralizing
antibodies against
the humonglu of the
virus. This is the
spike that attaches
to host cells to
cause infection.
And because of
antigenic drift, there
may be variations in
that spike protein
so that antibodies
varyingly bind to it.
If an antigenic shift
occurs, then most
of the population
is not immune. And
therefore, the
influenza vaccine won't
be expected to work
very well at all.
In a usual influenza
season, we usually
expect about a 50 to 70
percent effectiveness.
50 percent is the
lowest in most years.
But again, it
depends on how many
people are vaccinated.
And you can see
in the top graph
that in adults, it
really varies by
culture, ethnicity.
It also varies
year to year.
In general, these are for
adults. And in general,
children are
quite a bit higher
than this. But in
the last few years,
the number of
people getting
vaccinated for flu
has been dropping.
and it's also
geographic in the united
states we don't really
know why this is but
you can see on that
bottom graph that the
different states have
very different numbers
of people who are
getting vaccinated.
The measles vaccine,
this live attenuated
vaccine, causes
neutralizing antibodies
and a great T cell
response. It's
very effective after
two doses, about
90% or I'm sorry, 97%
immunity. But because
it is so contagious,
so many people
are infected by each
infected person.
The herd immunity
threshold is extremely
high, 95%. And we
were in the United
States above that
several years ago, about
98% in most regions
of the United States.
The WHO estimates that
between 2010 and 2018,
the measles
vaccine prevented
worldwide about
23 million deaths.
This was mostly from
measles pneumonia.
A lot of these
deaths occur in
low-income, low
-resource settings.
But again, there are
other complications of
measles that are
prevented by the vaccine.
So when you get
millions and millions of
people infected,
you see quite a bit
of SSPD, the subscorosing
pan encephalitis.
And there's also a
syndrome of immune
suppression that
occurs in children
after measles infection
that lasts about
two years that
results in increased
infections and some of
some fatal outcomes.
In a child who
has measles
infections, if they've
been vaccinated
prior to the
measles infection,
that measles infection
can completely
wipe out the
immunity that was
provided by all of
the prior vaccines.
I've got some graphs
on this and some
subsequent slides
that really show the
effect of vaccines.
The homophilus
influenzae type B
vaccine caused a dramatic
reduction in the
number of children who
presented with
otitis media, but it
just about eradicated
meningitis in children
from homophilus
influenzae type B.
there is also a
reduction in transmission
in unvaccinated
children due to the
herd effect those
cases of haemophilus
influenza infection
that we do see now are
mostly in adults who
have waning immunity
after having either
the vaccine or
infection to type B
haemophilus influenza,
or we see non type B
infection in children,
but to a much,
much lesser extent
than we used to
see haemophilus
influenza type
B infection.
there's a very similar
story for pneumococcus
or streptococcus
pneumoniae 45 percent
decrease in
hospitalizations 60 percent
or i'm sorry 68 percent
decrease in invasive
disease in children
with a 75 percent
decrease in mortality
um not the incredibly
drastic reductions we
see in the hib vaccine
mostly because there
are so many different
serotypes of
streptococcus pneumoniae
but as the newer
vaccines come out
these numbers are
dropping even more
the hepatitis b vaccine
has resulted in a
near total elimination
of mother to child
transmission with the
newborn dose in other words
the dose that's given
on the day of birth
Without that dose,
we're looking at about
40 to 50 cases of mother
to child transmission
per year in the United
States. Remember
that if you are
infected at birth, you
are much more likely
to have lifelong
infection with hepatitis
B as opposed to being
infected during
adulthood, which many
people will clear. the
vaccine has resulted
in a 99 percent
decrease in pediatric
prevalence in the united
states it's estimated
that from the years
2000 to 2030 this
vaccine will save 39
million lives worldwide.
The vaccine probably
gives you lifelong
immunity. And
remember, one of the
complications of hepatitis
B is hepatocellular
carcinoma. So we're
going to see a
dramatic decrease
in this cancer also.
So the HPV vaccine
is to prevent *******
warts, but even more
importantly cancers
that are caused by
the human papilloma
virus. There is a 56
to 71 percent decrease
in HPV prevalence
among adolescents and
young women since the
first administrations
of this vaccine.
Dramatic decrease in
HPV associated warts
and there is also a
significant herd effect
And when given before
the age of 17 years,
we expect an 80
to 90% decrease in
cervical cancer rates.
Some countries
are going for
eradication of cervical
cancer by using
this vaccine, for
example, Sweden.
of course to in
order to achieve that
it needs to be given
before ****** debut
and finally the SARS
-CoV-2 vaccine as we said
the mRNA the mRNA
vaccines are extremely
effective and provide
long-lasting immunity.
People who were
vaccinated were
protected from severe
disease and death.
By the time of the
Delta variant, which
was about the third
variant and the last
variant that really
caused large numbers
of people with severe
disease, Because
intensive care units
around the United States
were filled with
unvaccinated persons.
The hospitals were
too, but the intensive
care units were where
they were dying.
Really the vast
majority of those
who perished from
COVID-19 during
that time period
were unvaccinated.
Now, I don't feel that
you need to memorize
vaccine schedules
unless you do this on a
daily basis. It really
doesn't become second
nature, but you do know
where or you do have
to know where to look
for these schedules
or recommendations. For
example, when somebody
comes in and is
about to travel to a
foreign country in which
some of these diseases
are endemic. So, we
recommend that you look
at recommendations from
the American Academy
of Pediatrics, the
Infectious Diseases
Society, and the CDC,
and if someone is
traveling globally, or
if you are caring for
someone, say, on an
international trip, look
at recommendations from
the WHO and the CDC.
What you do have
to know is how to
talk to patients
about vaccines.
Vaccines have
probably saved
hundreds of millions
of lives worldwide
since their advent.
there really
isn't any
negotiation or let's
say controversy
about whether or
not they are safe
and effective.
Patients in general
fall into three
categories with regard
to vaccine. There
are those who take
them and have their
children vaccinated
and believe in them.
There are those that
are anti-vaxxers.
These are people who are
entrenched, dug in
in their belief,
and they are often
motivated by secondary
gain or things that
have nothing to
do with whether or
not vaccines work.
And then there are
the vaccine hesitant.
In general, those
who are vaccine
hesitant want to
do what is best
for their family
and themselves.
They are torn between
different voices,
and it is difficult
with the amount of
information that is
coming at them for them
to know who or what
to believe. And that's
where we as physicians
who care for our
patients come in and
have the most effect.
It is very, very
difficult to change the
mind of an anti-vaxxer.
They are entrenched.
They have different
reasons other
than health for
their views.
but it's not possible
patients want to
know who they can
trust they don't want
someone to lecture
them tell them they're
wrong or be frustrated
or short with
them they want someone
that they can have
a conversation with,
that is two-way.
So let's talk a
little bit about
what we can tell
our patients.
First, we need
to know where
our patients
are coming from.
Why is there non-vaccine
acceptance either
hesitancy or anti-vax
stances first there's
just some people who
don't feel like it's
relevant some people
don't feel like they
should be responsible
for herd immunity
some people feel like
they're immortal and
won't be affected by
an infectious disease
Lots of patients will
tell you, I never
get the flu and I've
never had the vaccine.
It's just the
luck of the draw.
Some people lack
understanding
of statistics,
study design,
how to interpret results.
and that's really
our role and responsibility
for interpreting
that so that patients
can understand. I
think that's one of the
things that we really
have an opportunity
on. We haven't done it
great but there is a
real opportunity there.
Some patients lack
the experience
of what it was like
before a vaccine
was available
for infections.
At the turn of the
20th century, we talked
about childhood
mortality by age five was
about 50%. No one
remembers that anymore.
but there are
places in the world
where that is
still the case
those are places
that don't have
vaccines and are
clamoring for them
um some people
misinterpret
the effect of vaccines
a common thing a
person might say or is
every time I get the
flu shot I get the
flu well as we talked
about the flu shots
don't have flu in
them you can't get the
flu from the flu
shot because there's
no replicating virus
so that flu that they
got was an immune
response and And
hopefully that immune
response actually is
the manifestation of
now they're immune.
So we call that
vaccine dragon,
but it's very,
very common.
We need to tell
patients that,
hey, you're protected
from the flu.
and if you were not
feeling well for a
day, maybe some fever,
that was a lot better
than one you being
infected by the
influenza and being
sick as a dog for five
days and or transmitting
that influenza
to your friends and
family and coworkers.
there is definitely
a lack of trust for
some of the health
care system and the
health care system is
not perfect physicians
are not perfect
and there are some
you know bad stories
in the history of
health care and that's
not going to stop
unfortunately but for
those of us who want
the best for our
patients, building a
trusting relationship
is very important.
There are cultural
barriers to seeking
care, but let's talk
a little bit about
what's been happening
over the maybe
past decade that's
a little bit
different than the
previous years.
There seems to
be a trend for
armchair
quarterbacking disease.
This has always
been present but the
extent to which it
is now present and
the self-validation
that some people
get from being a
source of information
seems to be much
more prevalent than
it used to be and
much more important
to those people
than it used to be.
Again, there's
nothing wrong with
being an armchair
quarterback.
There's definitely
something wrong
with being an
armchair quarterback
for a potentially
fatal infection.
Um,
these are emphasized
or made more strong
by, um, family contacts
and social networks,
um, that validate
these beliefs, um, and
something I call self
-validating isolationism
is when you only
associate yourself
with people who believe
what you believe.
You know, as scientists,
especially researchers,
we pose a question or
a study question as,
this is not true and I
have to prove that it is.
That is how research
is conducted.
And that is what
a scientist does.
That's not what
non-scientists do.
So if you surround
yourself with people who
agree with you, that
validates your belief.
You could even believe
that the world is flat.
This is made even
worse by social
media algorithms
that tend to
focus on fear
and negativity.
Now, I am not
going to blame any
social media company
for using those
algorithms because
on the right is a
newspaper. the
first social media,
and how do you sell
more newspapers,
you put fear
and that's the
stuff that sells
more papers.
So social media wants
you to be stuck on
their page and that's
the way to do it
exposing the numbers
of people in a way that
gets you sort of
addicted to the device
is a little bit different
than a newspaper
so um i think so very
a lot of the time
these social media
algorithms tend to
strengthen the self
-validating isolationist
And we as physicians
and healthcare
industry in general,
we really have an
opportunity for better
messaging. It is very
difficult to understand
the nuance of
scientific discovery,
changing our understanding
of illnesses and
cures over time.
the general population
many may see that
as waffle it when
it isn't it's just
that we are learning
as we go that is
science and lastly
there is a lot of
misinformation being
generated during our
times much of this
is secondary gain
It was said that
during the COVID
pandemic, when this
really exploded,
only 12 entities
were responsible for
about 80% of the
misinformation on the web.
So, again, we really
need to be fighting
hard for our patients
and giving them
good information that
is the truth to the
best of our knowledge,
validated by research
and studies, or
those who have very
loud voices will have
their ear instead.
So we have conversations
with our patients
about vaccines and
we try and transmit
information to our
patients that is the truth.
Let's talk about
some vaccine myths
and what the
actual truths are.
Vaccines don't
prevent infection.
You actually have
to be infected
for your immune system to
kick in and
produce antibodies.
Vaccines reduce the risk
of severe disease, death,
sequelae, and
complications of infection.
Inactivated or component
vaccines do not
replicate and therefore
do not cause disease.
Some vaccines result
in immune protection
that is more robust
than infection.
It is not true that
native infection
is better than
every vaccine.
Current vaccines were
either studied in
placebo-controlled
trials or with subsequent
generations of vaccines
were studied in
comparisons to vaccines
that were studied in
placebo-controlled
trials. And it would be
unethical to do it
otherwise because from
the first placebo
-controlled trials, We
know that patients do
better when they're
vaccinated, so having
subsequent generations
compared to a placebo
would be unethical.
Now, with the
exception of SARS-CoV
-2, which was a
pandemic that drove
economic
development and gave
resources to
pharmaceutical companies,
vaccines for infections
don't provide
significant revenue
for the industry.
Many times they are
actually money losers.
Side effects of
vaccines in general
are less prevalent
and sometimes
dramatically less
severe than the
similar effects of
native infection.
The effectiveness of
unstudied alternate
schedules can't predict
studied schedules.
The effectiveness
of unstudied
alternate
schedules cannot be
predicted by
studied schedules.
But there are more
and more studies
for alternate
schedules ongoing,
so we will know
more about that.
Eradication of disease
does not eradicate
circulating virus
in all cases.
It has in smallpox.
It hasn't in polio,
and that's because
of the oral polio
vaccine, and that
strain now circulates
in humans throughout
the world.
that's another story
and not for this
lecture but it is a
very interesting one
we'll talk a
little bit more
about that in a
subsequent slide
um antigen exposure
from almost all
vaccines is extremely
limited you're being
exposed to one,
maybe five antigens,
more for the
pneumococcal polyvalent
vaccines, but you are
exposed to new antigens
by the thousands
almost every day.
And vaccines don't
enter the host
cell nucleus or
alter the DNA.
Infectious Asians do.
there is currently no
u.s licensed vaccine
that contains aluminum
nor has aluminum
in vaccines been
linked to any disease
process when studied
the same is true
for thymeserol um this
was there was only
one vaccine in the u
.s licensed uh which
was the multi-dose
vial for influenza.
And I think that
was, no one's
manufacturing that
anymore as of last year.
But that was
the only one.
You didn't get
thimerosal from single
-dose syringes. So,
For example, if
you went to your
doctor or a pharmacy,
they probably
used a single-dose
syringe with no
exposure to thimerosal.
Vaccines don't
promote promiscuity or
dangerous behavior.
That has been studied.
and just to get you
to think anti-cancer
vaccines are now
being introduced for
treatment and you can
bet that there will
be anti-cancer
vaccines for prevention
now we're not talking
about infectious
diseases we're
talking about
preventing treating
and sooner or
later preventing
cancers and you can
bet there will be
vaccine hesitant
patients and anti
-cancer anti-vaxxers
so what should we
do if a patient
has a adverse
effect to a vaccine
There is the Vaccine
Adverse Event
Reporting System. I'm
not going to go into
that very much in
this slide because
that program is
currently undergoing
evolution, and I'm
really not sure what
it's going to look
like in the next
few months. But
essentially, patients,
health care providers,
or just about anyone,
can report an adverse
effect of a vaccine.
This is not a study.
You're more likely to
get someone to report
an adverse effect
if that effect is
severe. So there may be
an over-representation
of some adverse
effects or side effects
and an under
-representation of others.
So really, this was not
done in a study protocol.
So the statistics
or the conclusions
that you can derive
from this program
are limited, but they
are very important.
There have been
several signals from
this program that
have led to the
discovery of then
unknown adverse effects.
Most healthcare
providers feel that this
is a very important
program to continue.
The National Vaccine
Injury Compensation
Program is an alternative
to litigation that
was very common during
the 1970s and 1980s.
litigation from
vaccine side effects
was so common in the
1980s that we went
from about 15 or 20
vaccine manufacturers
to only two because
they were losing
so much money on in
court But whether
or not that's justified
or unjustified,
the difficulty of
potentially losing
manufacturing capability
of vaccines was felt to
be way too dangerous to
continue that process.
So the government,
the United States
government, came up with
the National Vaccine
Injury Compensation
Program, which is funded
by the vaccine
administrations themselves
from insurance
companies and patients.
I'll talk about that a
little bit on the next
slide. But essentially
what happens is a
patient makes a claim
that's reviewed by a
panel of government
officials and healthcare
providers, and there
is a settlement made
to the patient so that
they do not need to
go to court. While the
settlements are not
as lucrative as the
court judgments during
the 1980s, the process
was a lot simpler
and more money tended
to go to the patients.
And as you can see in
this slide, about $4
billion was paid out
from 1988 until 2019.
the good things about
this program was
that it was no fault
nobody was blamed the
companies weren't at
risk and that resulted
in a resurgence of
companies that were
willing to do vaccine
research and put
out new vaccines
that's why there are so
many today about 60
percent of the cases
were settled uh and
um a lot of times that
was quicker than going
to court and like
i said it's funded by
the costs of vaccine
administration about
75 cents for each
vaccine given was
taken out to fund this
program um the cons
though are many feel
that the wait time
is still way too long
that there is a high
rate of case dismissal.
You know, only 60% of
the cases can be settled.
You can say,
great, 60% of the
cases are settled,
or you can say
only 60% of cases
are settled.
But what really
puts this program in
jeopardy is as
vaccination rates fall,
the funding for
this program
will cease or not
be sufficient.
Okay, we're just
about done. Just a few
ethical considerations
of vaccination for you.
It is hard to,
or hard for patients
to understand
why herd immunity
is so important,
why young people should
be get vaccinated
for influenza to save
the very young and
the very old and the
immune suppressed.
As we have conversations
with our patients,
it is sometimes
very, very difficult,
especially if they are
anti-vaxxers, not to
have a very strong
emotional response.
But we have to remember,
we see our patients
for a lot of
other things other
than vaccinations.
So in order to continue
to care for them
And in order to have
opportunities to educate
them, we want to
continue to see them.
We can also learn a
lot from our patients.
And then I said
I was going to
talk about the
oral polio vaccine.
You know, we don't
use this in the United
States or in high
income countries
anymore for the fact
that this is a live
vaccine. It causes
an infection in those
vaccinated and in a
very small number of
those persons, they
get paralytic polio.
So, ethically, should
we be giving the
oral polio vaccine in
low-income settings
and not high-income
settings, given
the fact that there
is the risk of polio?
So the oral polio
vaccine is much easier
to give in low income
settings because
it does not require
long periods of
refrigeration and it's
easier to transport
and it's easier to
give. It's oral.
So really, it is an
ethical conundrum for
some and less so for
others. um it is all the
oral polio vaccine is
also the reason why
there are strains of
polio in waste water
throughout the world
which means that this
strain is circulating
throughout the world
in humans humans are
the only host for polio
and therefore if we
decrease our polio
vaccination rates, we will
begin to see paralytic
polio again, probably
from this strain.
So in summary, vaccines
create memory and
prevent severe outcomes.
Different vaccine
types create different
immune responses, and
vaccines protect
individuals and communities.
Vaccines prevent
infectious and non
-infectious disease
outcomes, and
clinicians must
understand the
immunology and
communicate effectively.
Thank you so much
for listening.
Please give us
feedback. We really do
value your opinion.
Everybody have a
safe and wonderful
rest of your day.